okay so CNN had what was it a seven hour
8 hour 7 hour 7 hour climate change Town
Hall yesterday with all the different
Democratic nominees I didn't watch a
single minute of it because I don't hate
myself personally the idea of watching 7
hours of that just is inhumane it I mean
you could argue that CNN has violated
all of our protections against cruel and
unusual punishment just by putting that
on the air and speaking of which and
again I don't know and this is a
question for you if you watched it
because as I said I didn't but was they
had a live studio audience right for the
7 hour thing was it the same audience
for those 7 hours was actually the same
collection of people who sat there for 7
hours watching as one Democratic nominee
after another got up there and talked
about climate rate I just I can't
imagine that if that's the case where
did they get these people were they all
on work release from the local prison
where they all you know sadomasochists
was this some sort of weird sexual
fetish thing for them I just I can't I
don't get it I can't possibly understand
it anyway so I'm not gonna I'm not going
to go through and break down everything
that was said I think that'd be
pointless though there were a couple of
notable moments I think looking at based
on on the replay here's here's maybe my
my favorite of all the of the clips I've
seen of it this is probably my my
favorite moment from this is from Cory
Booker watch this so my plan says that
we need to be are at a zero carbon
electric electricity by 2030 that's
that's 10 years from the time that I
will win the presidency of the United
States of America
poor old Cory poor poor Booker he says
he's gonna be president and the audience
treats it as a punchline
they actually laughed at home he said
he's gonna be President I swear I'm
really starting to feel sorry for Cory
Booker and this has been the weirdest
thing for me throughout this campaign
it's one of the reasons why I kind of
really resent
this political season because I found
myself actually at various points kind
of feeling sorry for cory booker joe
biden even eric's wall well at different
points i've even felt sorry for Beto
sometimes now I know they don't deserve
my pity but I just can't help it I'm a
I'm a kind and sensitive guy what can I
say that is those are my most prominent
personality traits according to no one
what I really want to discuss what I
want to focus on is one moment involving
Bernie Sanders but actually before we
get there this here's here's one here's
one thing with Andrew yang that I wanted
to talk about briefly watch watch this
so so what's the answer well we are we
all gonna have to drive electric cars we
are all going to love driving our
electric cars well we have to drive
electric cars well there will still be
some legacy gas guzzlers on the road for
quite some time because this is not a
country where you're going to like take
someone's you know like clunker away
from them but you are going to offer to
buy the clunker back and help them
upgrade so andrew yang wants the
government to buy everybody's car and
that's on top of that what is it a
thousand bucks a month we're gonna get
from the government under Yang's plan so
it appears that yang believes that the
government has literally an infinite
supply of money and he also appears to
believe that inflation is a myth it
doesn't exist because you could just
give people money by their cars is not
gonna have any inflationary impact on
the economy i I these are not serious
proposals from a serious person I just I
don't understand why people love this
guy so much
speaking of unserious people but in this
case a none serious person with
seriously evil ideas here is a
terrifying exchange involving Bernie
Sanders at the town hall last night
human population growth has more than
doubled in the past 50 years the planet
cannot sustain this growth I realize
this is a poison
this topic for politicians but it's
crucial to face empowering women and
educating everyone on the need to curb
population growth seems a reasonable
campaign to enact would you be
courageous enough to discuss this issue
and make it a key feature of a plan to
address climate catastrophe well the
answer is yes and the answer has
everything to do with the fact that
women in the United States of America by
the way have a right to control their
own bodies and make the decisions and
the mexico city agreement which denies
american aid to those organizations
around the world that are that allow
women to have abortions or even get
involved in birth control to me is
totally absurd so i think especially in
poor countries around the world where
women do not necessarily want to have
large numbers of babies and where they
can have the opportunity through birth
control to control the number of kids
they have something i very very strongly
us support let's let's just be clear
about what what happened there the
question was whether Bernie would
support abortion as a means to reduce
the population and save the planet and
he said that he would okay now the word
abortion was never used and so you're
gonna hear in fact I've already heard
some people try to rationalize this by
saying well no what he was talking about
birth control not abortion yeah he did
he did mention birth control also which
he lumps in with abortion because
abortion is a form of birth control in
Bernie Sanders his mind but he was also
referring explicitly to abortion that's
what the whole bit about women could do
what they want with their bodies that's
abortion okay that's that always refer
somewhere that's not birth control
because there isn't anybody out there
who despite what you hear from the left
there isn't anyone out there who is
trying to make birth control illegal or
whatever that's that's not an argument
that anyone's having so there's no one
saying that women shouldn't have the
right to use birth control there are
people saying that women shouldn't have
the right to kill their babies and so
when someone says is what
and have the right to they're talking
about abortion and so that's what he
wants to do he he is this is Bernie
Sanders supporting eugenics explicitly
plain and simple now this of course is
not surprising it's not new eugenics has
been around for over a hundred years as
it happens Bernie Sanders has also been
around for over a hundred years probably
not a coincidence and American leftist
have supported eugenics in some form or
another using direct or indirect
rhetoric for that entire time in fact
the whole idea of abortion support for
abortion rests inherently on a eugenics
mentality it rests on the
commodification of human life that is
seeing human life judging the worth of
human life according to its usefulness
to society saying that human life has
subjective worth determined by other
people determined by society as a whole
based on how useful or or unuseful that
human life is to society all
pro-abortion people see human life this
way they all do they must in order to be
pro-abortion so it's not a big leap it's
not a leap at all actually to go from
that to let's kill babies because there
are too many people on earth so we
shouldn't be shocked by this and by the
way every pro-abortion person agrees
with what Bernie Sanders just said even
if they won't admit it out loud they all
agree they all do of course meanwhile on
this overpopulation idea it should be
stipulated that overpopulation is
mythological okay it's not real the
world is not running out of room or
running out of resources that is a myth
it is a fable told especially by people
who want to justify the genocide of the
unborn we could just to give you an idea
I mean the earth is is a very very big
place Carolyn on an astronomical level
it's it's not consist it's not a very
big planet there are a lot of bigger
planets out there but it is
it's as far as we're concerned from our
perspective it is a very very big planet
you could take we've got what seven
billion people on earth now you could
take them all and fit them all in the
state of Texas every single person on
earth could fit into the state of Texas
with their own town houses and their own
nice little postage stamp yards with a
picket fence and everything you could
now there wouldn't be a lot of room and
and and you know a factoid like that can
be a little deceptive in that you know
it is also true that much of the surface
area of the earth is not it cannot be
inhabited is not a bit of a bita 'but
abble there we go it's not habitable you
know Antarctica for instance but the
fact remains that there is a lot a lot a
lot a lot of habitable area on earth
where where nobody currently lives and
it will be that way indefinitely okay so
we've got a lot of space and we also
have enough food for everybody there's
enough resources there's enough food
there's enough space anyone telling you
otherwise is simply lying or they're
mistaken and now we do have a problem
and I hesitate to use this word because
of the implications of it but we do have
a problem with the distribution of the
food and the space in that there's a lot
there are some people on earth who have
a lot of food and waste it and a lot of
space and wasted and then there are some
people who have not enough food and they
starve if they don't have enough space
ok we know that and when I say
distribution I'm not saying that we need
some big government entity to just to
redistribute it that's not what I'm
saying but it is there is a
disproportionate it is disproportionate
in the way this stuff is is allotted
that's true but that's not because there
are too many people and the way that I
know that is that you know back when
there were a billion people on earth or
a hundred million or ten million there
were still a lot of people probably
proportionally more than there are today
who were starving and we're living in
filth and we're living in crowded
environments
and that's back wouldn't there were you
know there was a quarter of the number
of people on earth or less than that so
it's not a matter of there being too
many people that's not the problem the
solution then is to talk about how to
address the issues of poverty and and
you know and all of that and that's a
good thing to talk about we could talk
we can have that discussion
Bernie's solution is to just kill them
is to say well there there are people on
earth who are poor poor families and so
let's just start killing them off
killing their children anyway and that
leads me to something else this is kind
of interesting
have you noticed I'm sure you have that
the people who advocate reducing the
population to save the planet always
want to start by killing babies have you
noticed that which that does not really
seem like the most logical place to
start it but poor babies especially we
should we should mention so they say
there's too many people on earth we got
to start getting rid of people not just
let's prevent more people from being
conceived but we have to actually get
rid of some people who have already been
conceived and so the people who say that
say well let's begin with the with the
babies especially poor babies they never
seem to see themselves as members of the
surplus population in need of
extermination what a strange coincidence
that is I mean if you really if you
really think the world is overpopulated
and the solution is to kill people you
could contribute to the solution in a
more direct way now I'm not advocating
I'm not advocating suicide I'm not
advocating the people who believe in
overpopulation go out and commit mass
suicide I'm not I don't think they
should I'm just saying that maybe stop
trying to throw babies into the fire if
you're not willing to go there yourself
if there is a surplus population if
that's really a thing where there are
too many people well how do you know
you're not part of the surplus and it
would seem like again if that's true the
most direct solution would be for you to
at least make sure that you're not part
of the problem and also the word consent
is supposed to be very meaningful these
days
well the babies don't consent to you
might say that there's overpopulation we
don't have room for them the babies
aren't don't consent to - you know -
being killed you
you can consent to it so it just it just
seems to me that that would be the most
direct solution if you really think that
there's a problem of that sort think
about think about Bernie Sanders first
for for a second here specifically now
it's morally atrocious for anyone to get
up there and advocate for killing babies
in order to curb population growth so
for anyone to do that is is disgusting
and evil and everything but it's all the
more grotesque and cowardly and just
egregious to have an elderly man pushing
80 years old getting up there and
setting that Bernie Sanders is he he
doesn't have that meant much time left
he's most people the average life
expectancy for a man is I think is 84 or
it might be less than that most people
don't make it to 90 few people do you're
almost definitely not making it to a
hundred the the most likely scenario is
that Bernie Sanders is dead anyway
within 10 years because of his age
that's just that's that's what the
statistics tell us and as he continues
to age he's going to become more and
more of a burden on people around he's
gonna become less and less able to
contribute to society and more and more
of a burden - up - to society and to his
family and so on that's that's the
trajectory that we all follow if we if
we live long enough
so again if you really have this
utilitarian materialistic view of human
life and if you really think that well
look you know babies we don't need them
there there's too many people get if
that's really how you see it and if
that's really how we're judging human
life and so now we have to start getting
rid of surplus people it would almost
seem like it would make more sense to
begin with people on the other end of
the life spectrum because yeah with with
babies it's true that when they're born
for a time they're going to not be able
to contribute they're going to be for
lack of a better term a burden on their
parents but that's not going to last
forever
in theory eventually they're going to go
on and be on their own and contribute to
society and they've got all the
potential in the world they could go on
and cure cancer or or they could do
anything right but if you're 80 years
old then whatever potential you had has
probably mostly been realized or not
realized and you're you're going more
into the phase of being a burden and
you're never going to come out of that
phase so it just seems to me if if this
is what we're doing if we're getting rid
of surplus people it seems like we
should start with adults it's not just
older adults even someone like you know
me I'm 33 years old if there was any
chance that I was gonna cure cancer it's
I've gone in a different direction I've
done this instead maybe I could have
cured cancer but I decided to do this
instead so I'm probably never gonna cure
cancer you know I'm probably never gonna
contribute that much to society I mean
this is probably the most I'm gonna do
and so you know hey maybe maybe maybe I
get tossed on the scrapheap too I don't
know it's just to begin with babies
makes no sense to me even from the from
the as I said utilitarian materialistic
view point of
or maybe you know maybe this whole line
of thinking is just horrific alida
ranged and wrong and maybe we shouldn't
be looking at human life this way no
matter how old or young a person happens
to be okay maybe your value and worth is
not derived based on how useful you are
to other people or what society can do
with you or or how many people there
already are on earth or whatever else
and maybe even if you are a you know a
quote-unquote burden to other people if
you have to be taken care of maybe that
doesn't detract from your worth at all
in any sense maybe that's the way to
look at it that's my vote I vote for
that I think that's how we should look
at it but if we are going to look at it
that way we can't just apply it to
ourselves I can't just say well know me
I mean yeah everybody else may be there
they can be surplus population we don't
need them but me know I'm infinitely
valuable and worthy that doesn't make
any sense if nobody else is that I'm not
either but if I am then everybody is and
so I think as a society we just have to
decide what kind of society we want to
be because we're we were trying to play
both we've been trying to play both
sides of the fence for a while now we're
on one hand what do we tell kids we say
oh you're you're special you're
wonderful it doesn't matter how anyone
thinks of you or what they say about you
you're a wonderful special infinitely
valuable person on one hand we say that
on the other hand those very same kids
when they were in the womb we said
they're expendable we can exterminate
them kill them slaughter them dismember
them throw them in the dumpster can't
have it both ways
which way is it going to be I vote for
let's treat all life as valuable and
infinitely worthy but if you want to go
the other way and say fine let's just
live in a utilitarian materialistic
eugenics you know driven hellscape if
that's what you want to do okay but I
what you're gonna find is that it's not
just gonna be the babies who end up on
the scrap heap all right this was this
was kind of funny I just I wanted to
mention this there was I think every
every week we have to do one of these
crazy feminists on Twitter updates and
so a crazy feminist on Twitter sent out
a viral tweet it's getting a lot of
reaction this woman's name is Charlotte
and here's what she said she says and
I'm by the way 9 I'm 98% sure this is
not satire or parody I'm 98% sure she's
being sincere although she has blocked
me now so I can't really investigate too
much but here's what she said men before
you tell a joke / give advice Platt /
pay a compliment I need you to ask
yourself three questions
one was I invited to speak to will what
I'm about to say be welcome three am i
speaking to enrich this person or am i
speaking just to make myself seen was I
invited here this is what she meant
this is what Charlotte a woman named
Charlotte a feminist on Twitter this is
what she needs us to do she needs it
okay we have been given our instructions
and so anytime you want to speak to
anyone you have to first first wait for
an invitation I don't know can we ask
for the invitation are we allowed to say
may I speak
but then if to say that we're all we are
already speaking without an invitation
so I guess we have to just stand there
silently until a woman turns to us and
says you are now invited to speak you
have 25 seconds go
of course it's useless to say that
Charlotte is not following her own
advice here because she was not invited
to tweet this it was not welcome and it
certainly didn't enrich anyone or
anything except for her own ego but that
doesn't matter because she's a woman so
it doesn't apply to her this just again
shows and we should remember that as
much as we might we might like to
believe otherwise Charlotte is not alone
in this
there are a lot of college-aged feminist
women who this is how they see the world
and this is how they see men this is how
they're told to see men but I think what
you find here it never ends it never
ceases to amaze me how feminists just
don't it's not even that they don't
understand men which of course they
don't but they don't even know they
don't understand human communication
they don't they don't understand humans
they're like robots or something this is
not how human communication works it
reminds me of those of the feminist
affirmative consent laws that you find
on a lot of college campuses these days
to alleviate the supposed rape epidemic
on college campuses where you know the
firm ative consent means that if a young
man is in a romantic embrace with a
young woman he must be given affirmative
consent throughout the sexual act which
means as it progresses he he must ask
the woman can we continue and she has to
say yes we can and there has to be
affirmative throughout the entire thing
that has to be his continued affirmative
verbal consent which obviously is is
crazy and that's just not how human
beings work that's that's not how it
works aren't like that
that's how computers operate and it
seems like feminists don't understand
the difference between human beings and
computers which is a fascinating fact
all right here's something that may not
be of any great interest to most of you
but I'm gonna babble about it anyway Max
Kellerman a talking head on ESPN went
off on a rant yesterday on his show on
ESPN about how track-and-field
isn't really a sport and it's inferior
to things like basketball and football
I'm not sure how this came up or why
they were talking about it but they were
I don't have the clip to play you but
that's the summary track isn't a real
sport it's not as pure as football and
basketball and and look I'm a football
fan and a basketball fan at least during
the playoffs but
but this is absolutely ridiculous and
maybe I am biased as someone who I ran
track in high school I also enjoy
running as a hobby at least I did before
my Achilles tear and ever since then
then I become sort of a fat lazy slug
unfortunately but still I can say that
track track and field is not only a
sport but I think it's actually the
purest and rawest sport in in existence
there's no luck there's no chance
there's nothing to hide behind you think
about it even a great quarterback can
get bailed out by a wide receiver making
a fantastic catch and a quarterback the
winds if we talk about a the win-loss
record of a quarterback or the win-loss
record of a basketball player or a
pitcher their win-loss record is going
to be determined not just by them but by
their their teammates and it's gonna
have at least as much to do with their
team as it does with them personally if
not probably more with their team than
them personally none of that applies to
track I mean unless we're talking about
relay races but if we're talking about
just a straight 100-meter dash or my
event in high school is a 1600 meter
mile it's just you your speed your
strength your stamina your mental and
physical endurance and that's it that's
all you've got
can you get to the finish line before
the next guy before everybody else on
the track if you do you win if you don't
you lose and that's it there aren't any
lucky bounces there aren't any lucky
catches aren't any lucky errors made by
someone in the outfield so you can get
on second base it's just do you have the
speed and strength to beat everybody
else that's it if you do you win if you
don't you lose and that's a sport that's
about as sporty as sports get so here's
how it breaks down because this whole
conversation about what's a sport what
isn't a sport gets people very heated
and emotional myself as well so let me
try to explain this
you have three categories that are kind
of on a continuum as I see it you have
sports games and then physical arts
let's say a sport can be defined
a physical competition requiring
physical effort and skill between
contenders that can be won according to
an objective set of rules okay that's a
sport a game is a competition relying
more on strategy or chance than physical
ability which can be won according to a
objective set of rules and then a
physical art is a performative display
requiring strength and agility and
athleticism and grace which is judged
subjectively according to largely
aesthetic measures that's that's how
that's how all those things are defined
I sort of made all those definitions up
but I think I think they're they're good
so according to that football is both a
game and a sport and a little bit of an
art but it's none of those things purely
or completely it's sort of to a certain
degree all of them but not completely
any of them same for basketball hockey
baseball track on the other hand is to
no extent a game or an art it is just a
sport that's all it is 100% sport pure
sport all physical all strength all
objective there's no judging you might
have it you have a judge on the track to
tell you if you who cross the finish
line first or did you step out of but
but that's not that's not subjective you
have a date or you didn't something like
gymnastics is not a sport at all it is
pure art because it is all subjective
in most gymnastic events there is no way
to win except by a judge subjectively
assessing how you looked while you were
doing it that's an art that's not a
sport and then something like poker is
just or you know that's just pure game
that's not bowling okay that's just a
game it's not a sport it's not an art so
that's how it all breaks down and then
soccer is none of those things
soccer is just an activity for women and
children to play when they're bored I
guess that's how so I think we could
just put that all to rest there's a
continuum and that's how all that stuff
and by the way it's not when I say
gymnastics isn't a sport that's not an
insult
it's to be an art is a wonderful thing
it's just it's not the same kind of
thing all right let's
we'll go to emails Matt well show a
Gmail that cup actually I also wanted to
mention I finally watched the
live-action Aladdin movie with my kids
yesterday at their insistence I didn't
want to see it because as I've shared
before I think the whole remade the
live-action remakes of cartoons is a
stupid cash grab and I don't want to
support it but they convinced me to
watch it with them and honestly I'll
never forgive them for doing that to me
because it was much worse than even I
expected it was really really bad
I mean I'm amazingly bad it was so bad
that I could almost recommend it because
it was so bad just so you could gawk at
the at the poor quality of it it was
amazing it was like a high school stage
production of Aladdin but with worse
acting and here's what I'm trying to
figure out this is this is a thing
that's been that's been perplexing me
ever since I watched it with my kids
okay so you're if you're Disney you have
billions of dollars at your disposal you
have hundreds of millions that you can
spend on this movie how do you end up
with bad actors that's what got me the
whole time I'm watching the acting is so
bad how could you end up with bad actors
I mean I knew that it would lack the
charm wit and originality of the of the
first one I knew that and it did
severely so but I wasn't expecting the
acting to be so bad how does that happen
you can pay whoever you want you can get
whoever you want in Hollywood probably
to be in this thing and you end up with
bad actors but then I realized of course
I know what happened that these days
especially with with companies like
Disney the first priority is to make
sure that your actors will pass the
identity politics test okay they have to
be sufficiently ethnically pure
according to whatever character they're
playing and that's and that really is
the only priority now so Disney was made
they were making a live-action Aladdin
remake some
that's set in the Middle East and so
it's it's just a land mine for them if
your pardon that that that metaphor but
it's a it's a landmine because they know
that okay now they have these are Arabic
characters and so they've really got to
make sure that all of the actors they
find are sufficiently Arabic I think
that that's they decided that's the only
thing that matters doesn't actually
matter if they can really act all that
matters is do they pass the test
politically and they did they passed
that test unfortunately they couldn't
act and so that's what's happening it's
gotten so ridiculous now that the latest
outrage that I just saw this morning is
there's a movie coming out starring
Dakota Fanning playing a white at least
this is how it's being phrased she's
playing a white Ethiopian Muslim and
this is a movie about a real person who
was a British a white British woman who
moved to Ethiopia became a naturalized
citizen and was also a Muslim I don't
know if she converted or she was
originally people are outraged by that I
don't even understand it now somehow
that's that's offensive for Dakota
Fanning Dakota Fanning is a white woman
playing an actual white woman what are
we now at the point where you're just
not allowed to have white actors in a
movie at all even if they're playing
white characters I think that's that's
where this is headed that you just
you're you can't have it's if it's a
white you white actors aren't allowed to
play anybody anymore
it doesn't matter who they are doesn't
matter who they're playing they can't
play anybody I think that's where we're
headed and it's obviously absurd alright
Matt well show at gmail.com Matt well
show that email Commons email address
this is from Mike says dear Matt Walsh
thank you for giving us your input
regarding the Harry Potter controversy
in your latest podcast on a similar note
I am a devout Christian and wanted to
know your opinion about renaissance
festivals are these
just an excuse for people to gather and
create fantasies of Witchcraft etc so
overall do you approve of these events
or not thank you for your wisdom into
this pressing matter is this a thing are
there people who are there Christians
who say that Christians shouldn't go to
renaissance festivals because there's
witchcraft I went to one Renaissance
Festival a long time ago the only thing
I remember is the big delicious turkey
leg and and that's all that I remember
and honest I don't remember any
witchcraft but honestly if there was a
little bit of witchcraft I think it was
probably worth it for the turkey leg
which was really good this is from j-mac
says after noon my team at master driver
and owner of the superfly button-ups i
thank you for noticing I enjoyed your
take on faith and reason the other day
you did a good job using reason to
explain reasons purpose towards faith
although this did have the effect of
leaving faith by the wayside to me it
came across as your reason trying to
justify its own importance as reason
instead of an augment to faith
I wanted to attempt to explain that I
cotta be of faith and reason as best I
could
despite faith being an ineffable entity
that recoils all words that try and pin
it down reason is definitely a handy
tool used to familiarize ourselves to
the world we live in a cartographer can
reason a triangle on a map to become the
symbol of a mountain however a triangle
does not encompass all that is the
mountain reason is our limited and
flawed perspective struggling best they
can to iron out the mysteries of the
world we name the organs on the body
though their names would not dictate or
explain the organs function there is
much we don't know about God God's
organs perceptions plans we do however
have the ability to feel his divinity
and hear his voice faith is that feeling
of oneness with God it doesn't require
you to know him but it opens the channel
of knowing to use reason is to use the
language of humans faith would be the
language of God the feeling in your
bones that there is forgiveness and evil
one day be exhumed from the corpse of
man's relation to sin you don't need
language or understanding to tap into
serendipity if anything language becomes
a barrier to divinity as we try and
express God through language instead of
an all-encompassing form reason is the
prediction of events based on seen
experience and knowledge faith is the
knowing that the
we'll always be a silver lining sorry if
this doesn't make much sense I tried my
best with limited tools I have been
provided well Jay Mac I think that was
beautifully put actually I I would maybe
counter not even counter because I don't
I don't disagree fundamentally with with
most of what you said there but I would
add that to me reason is in this in it
the simplest definition for reason I
think is that it is our ability to
contemplate and understand I think
that's what reason is and I think that's
why we are reasonable creatures and
squirrels and and you know worms and
fish are not they can think they can
probably feel but they don't contemplate
abstract concepts they don't come to an
understanding they don't sit down and
say to themselves gee let me let me try
to really understand this thing over
here so in this sense if this is what
reason is and and and I think that's the
case then reason is inextricably tied to
faith so much so that I don't think you
can really put them in different
categories so when you say that I would
that I was advocating reason and putting
faith to the wayside I don't think
that's possible I think that they're
sort of dimensions of the same thing
because to say something like I think
God exists or I think God created the
universe now you you I guess you would
say that's a statement of faith and it
is but it's also a statement of reason
just the same because in order to make
that statement you first have to know
what it means for a thing to be created
you have to know what the universe is
and that one exists and you have to have
some basic idea of what God is you know
you say God you have to know none of us
can know God completely but when we say
we believe in God we have to have some
idea of what we believe in that word has
to mean something to us and so I think
all of that is reason right knowing what
the universe
is knowing what it is to create having
some idea of God understanding that
everything that exists must originate
somewhere I mean all of these things are
related to reason in addition to faith
and so I as I said I just I don't think
you can separate them this is from
Corbin says hey man I'm a high school
student and I have a very good smart
friend however she doesn't believe in
the moon landing I've tried to convince
her but beliefs are very firm
she believes that since no one can prove
it without citing NASA it is therefore a
cover-up I've talked to teachers about
it and they have agreed with her they've
agreed with her is there a point to
continuing this argument and if so how
should I argue this well Corbin first of
all the fact that your teachers agreed
with her is horrifying though also not
surprising but there's an old saying
that that's that says you can't reason
somebody out of a position that they
weren't reasoned into to begin with
meaning your friend did not adopt this
belief because she seriously studied the
issue objectively considered the
evidence and arrived at this conclusion
she might claim that's what she did but
I guarantee you that's not what she did
because nobody who does that could
possibly come to the conclusion that the
moon landing was it was a hoax you can
only come to that conclusion if you have
if the quote research you've done has
consisted of googling specifically these
conspiracy sites and looking only at the
information they provide you and not
looking at any other sources that's the
only way you can maintain a belief that
is so delusional and divorced from
reality and so that we know that that's
all she's done which means again
speaking of speaking of reason she was
not reasoned into that belief it is an
unreasonable belief that she adopted
because for what because she wanted to
believe it now why does she want to
believe that the moon landing never
happened you know I don't know that's a
whole separate conversation and we've
talked about that before why do people
want to believe these crazy conspiracy
theories I think there are a whole host
of reasons and probably the most simple
is just that
they find it exciting where they it's
kind of cinematic they sort of want to
live in a world where there are these
shadowy conspiratorial forces that are
doing stuff like that it makes them feel
like they're in a James Bond movie or
something which of course even if it's
true that the world the world would be
more exciting that way that doesn't make
it that doesn't that doesn't mean that's
not evidence that it actually happened
but also that it's it's I think it's way
more exciting way more exciting to
contemplate the fact that we actually
did land on the moon so but anyway
that's that's the psychology of it and
we could that's a different question but
this is an irrational belief that's the
point and you know we all have some
irrational beliefs it's part of being a
human being unfortunately this is one of
hers and all you can do I think is just
give her the facts which maybe you've
already done make sure she's been
exposed to those facts so that so that
she she at least has them in her orbit
part in the the pun and then wait for
her to grow out of this on her own and
she probably will eventually but that's
the thing when somebody has an
irrational unreasonable belief they have
to get to a point where they're willing
to sort of step out of that and actually
look objectively at the situation and
there's nothing you can do to force them
to do that and as long as they're
unwilling to step out of those beliefs
for a moment at least and look
objectively at the evidence as long as
they're unwilling to do that there's
nothing you can say in the moment that's
going to convince them but you can plant
the seed put the information there and
eventually when she grows up a little
bit maybe she'll venture out into the
world of reality
and say to herself oh you know what
korban was actually right about that
although unfortunately she'll probably
never come back to you and say you know
what you were right because that's also
unfortunately part of human nature
but thanks for the email thanks for the
question thanks everybody for watching
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer his
Austin Stephens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you want to delve the depths of leftist
madness head on over to the Michael
Noel's show where we examine what's
really going on beneath the surface of
our politics and bask in the simple joys
of being right
[Music]